look here's the deal you're number one
wealth building tool is your income all
of the millionaire's that we interview
unless they inherited the money which is
very very few of them less than 10% of
them inherited the money did it by
saving and investing their income they
did not give their income to Sallie Mae
they did not give their income to Best
Buy they don't get screwed around and
give their income to Lexus and Toyota
and Ford and General Motors and American
distress and Master Card who named that
anyway it's a mathematical thing when
you give your income to someone else you
don't have it anymore huh this is hard
this is hard isn't it and when you give
your income away you have given up your
economic future all for crap for a
stinking flat-screen for sign and let me
just tell you here's the deal you know
of the number of people that start
college how many graduate 52% that's an
investment in my future said the other
48 percent that are sitting at home with
no freaking degree but by god they got
the student loan debt and you know how
you get rid of Sallie Mae you either pay
her off in full or you die that's the
only way that woman goes away it's not
bankrupt able it is not an investment in
yourself to borrow even if it is an
investment we don't borrow money for
investments we don't borrow money for
investments I don't teach people to
borrow money the borrower is slave to
the lender that's what this math says
when you give up your income when you
give your income away
you have nothing all the money comes in
all the money goes out but by god we're
sitting around counting our Discover
points oh we got airline miles
Oh Sallie Mae's been with us for 15
freakin years in our spare bedroom all
because we called it an investor
and I don't understand why it's bad it's
bad because it's stupid and your normal
70% of the pecans are living paycheck to
paycheck that's stupid because you're in
living in one of the wealthiest
countries the world has ever known and
there you sit like a rat in a wheel run
run run run run
why because student loans are an
investment and I'm going to Best Buy
this is just stupid it's stupid on
steroids
really seriously you've got to stop and
think the level of people's ability to
do critical thought is almost zero good
lord are good airline miles said no
millionaire ever really millionaires do
I bet with thousands and thousands of
millionaires I've never met one that
said you know David I made my money with
my airline miles
all those Discover points broke me
through financially hey let's do the
math okay you know you get a thousand
dollars back from Discover you spend a
hundred thousand
how does spending a hundred thousand to
get a thousand back ever make you rich
where did you take your math class
really
this is absolutely ludicrous but
everybody's counting their dadgum points
and everybody's trying to figure out
some way I'm getting them I'm beating up
on chase check your chases kicking your
butt their buildings bigger than yours
and their furniture is nicer than yours
you ought to have a clue by now at the
carpet and I got a carpet bigger in your
house payment some of you average car
payment America now is $499 that's
suspiciously like five hundred bucks if
you take five hundred dollars a month
and invest it from age 30 to age 70
you'll have would you believe it you're
gonna have over five million dollars and
you scratch your head and wonder why
you're freaking broke God you know what
are your kids students that no wonder
your students have student loans because
you're driving a dadgum million dollar
car two million three million dollar car
that's what it's costing you with your
stupid car payment to impress somebody
to stoplight that you will never meet
and the things going down and value like
a rock we have to stop and think America
you have to think instead of sitting
around eating skittles and watching
Oprah reruns this is stupid
we're fat and
broke because we have no ability to do
critical thought and we don't stop and
look at what we're putting into our
lives this is nuts
it's nuts it's completely out of control
I mean the number of people I've talked
to just today with twenty five and
thirty thousand dollars out on their
stupid car it's a car good god it's a
car what does it do it takes you from
here to there now mind you having a
twenty five thousand dollar car all of
my cars cost more than twenty five
thousand but I freaking paid for them
and they're a very small percentage of
my life a very small percentage of my
income think think think
seriously so credit cards stupid stupid
student loans stupid car payments stupid
on steroids borrowing money on your
house to put granite countertops in
somebody ought to smack you
that's stupid it's stupid you have to
stop and think again it's because you're
killing yourself you make enough money
to retire a millionaire or a
multi-millionaire you make enough money
that your kids ought to have a college
fund fully funded and they can go to
school without being part of the freakin
student loan crisis but by god you had
to have a bass boat so you're thirty two
thousand dollars in debt because those
fish were out running you God think
think think
quit being grown-up children walking
around in grown-up buddies adults divide
imeem children walking around a grown up
buddies adults devise a plan and follow
it children do what feels good this
ridiculous impulsive nature if we think
we're going to borrow our way into
wealth is it's out of control guys we've
got to stop this it's killing you it's
killing you well I'm sitting over here
piling up money like it's dadgum nothing
and some of you are sitting there broke
wife and then going over to borrow money
a bus bah oh geez I'm gonna kill you
seriously I'm gonna go and get a student
loan and invest in myself yeah you're
going to spend a hundred and forty
thousand dollars and go in debt and get
a degree in freakin left-handed puppetry
that's just dad gum stupid it's just
stupid you have to think people you have
to think quit giving your most powerful
building tool away it's your income
you're making everybody else wrench Fink
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]